do you ever find herself referencing a
study and conversation that you didn't
actually read I was having coffee with a
friend of mine the other day and I said
you know I run a new study that says
coffee reduces the risk of depression
and women but really what I read was a
tweet that said a new study says
drinking coffee may decrease depression
risk in women and that tweet had a link
the New York Times blog where a guest
blogger translated the study findings
from a live science article which got
its original information from the
Harvard School of Public Health News
site which cited the actual study
abstract which summarized the actual
study published in an academic journal
it's like the six degrees of separation
but with research so when I said I read
a study what I actually read was 59
characters that summarized 10 years of
research so when I said I read a study I
was reading fractions of the study that
were put together by four different
writers that were not the author before
it got to me that doesn't seem right but
accessing original research is difficult
because academics aren't regularly
engaging with popular media and you
might be asking yourself why aren't
academics engaging with popular media it
seems like they'd be a more legitimate
source of information than the media
pundits
write in a country with over 4,100
colleges and universities it feels like
this should be the norm but it's not so
how do we get here
to understand why scholars aren't
engaging with popular media you first
have to understand how universities work
now in the last six years I've taught at
seven different colleges and
universities in four different states
I'm a bit of an adjunct extraordinaire
and at the same time I'm pursuing my PhD
in all of these different institutions
the research and publication process
works the same way first scholars
produce research in their fields to fund
their research they apply for public and
private grants and after the research is
finished they write a paper about their
findings then they submit that paper to
relevant academic journals then it goes
through a process called peer review
which essentially means that other
experts are checking it for accuracy and
credibility and then once it's published
for profit companies resell that
information back to universities and
public libraries through journal and
database subscriptions so that's the
system research right peer review
publish repeat my friends and I call it
feeding the monster and you can see how
this might create some problems the
first problem is that most academic
research is publicly funded but
privately distributed every year the
federal government spends 60 billion
dollars on research according to the
National Science Foundation 29% of that
goes to public research universities so
if you're quick at math that's seventeen
point four billion dollars tax dollars
and just five corporations are
responsible for distributing most
publicly funded research in 2014 just
one of those companies made one point
five billion dollars in profit it's a
big business and I bet you can see the
irony here if the public is funding
academics research but then we have to
pay again to access the results it's
like we're paying for it twice and the
other major problem is most academics
don't have a whole lot of incentive to
publish out
side of these prestigious
subscription-based journals universities
build their tenure and promotion systems
around the number of times scholars
publish so books and journal articles
are kind of like a form of currency for
scholars publishing articles helps you
get tenure and more research grants down
the road but academics are not rewarded
for publishing with popular media so
this is the status quo the current
academic ecosystem but I don't think it
has to be this way we can make some
simple changes to flip the script so
first let's start by discussing access
universities can begin to challenge the
status quo by rewarding scholars for
publishing not just in the
subscription-based journals but in open
access journals as well as unpopular
media now the open access movement is
starting to make some progress in many
disciplines unfortunately some other big
players have started to notice Google
Scholar has made open access research
searchable and easier to find Congress
last year introduced a bill that
suggests that academic research projects
with over 100 million or more in funding
should develop an open access policy and
this year NASA opened up its entire
research library to the public so you
can see this ideas beginning to catch on
but access isn't just about being able
to get your hands on a document or a
study it's also about making sure that
that document or study is easily
understood so let's talk about
translation I don't envision this
translation to look like the six degrees
of separation that I ate udderly err
instead what if scholars were able to
take the research that they're doing and
translated on popular media and be able
to engage with the public
if scholars did this the degrees of
separation between the public and
research would shrink by a lot so
see I'm not suggesting and dumbing down
of the research I'm just suggesting that
we give the public access to that
research and that we shift the venue and
focus on using plain language so that
the public who's paying for the research
can also consume it and there are some
other benefits to this approach by
showing the public how their tax dollars
are being used to fund research they can
begin to redefine universities
identities so that universities
identities are not just based on a
football team or the degrees they grant
but on the research that's being
produced there and when there's a
healthy relationship between the public
and scholars and encourages public
participation in research can you
imagine what that might look like
what if social scientists helped local
police redesign their sensitivity
trainings and then collaboratively wrote
a manual to model future trainings or
what if our education professors
consulted with our local public schools
to decide how we're going to intervene
with our at-risk students and then wrote
about it in a local newspaper because a
functioning democracy requires that the
public be educated and well informed
instead of research happening behind
paywalls and bureaucracy wouldn't it be
better if it was unfolding right in
front of us now as a PhD student I
realize I'm critiquing the club I want
to join which is the dangerous thing to
do since I'm gonna be on the academic
job market and a couple of years but if
the status quo in academic research is
to publish in the echo chambers of
for-profit journals that never reach the
public
you better believe my answer is going to
be nope I believe an inclusive
democratic research that works in the
community and talks with the public I
want to work in research and an academic
culture where the public is not only
seen as a valuable audience but a
constituent up
participant and in some cases even the
expert and this isn't just about giving
you guys access to public to access to
information it's about shifting academic
culture from publishing to practice and
from talking to doing and you should
know that this idea this hope it doesn't
just belong to me I'm standing on the
shoulders of many scholars teachers
librarians and community members who
also advocate for including more people
in the conversation I hope you join our
conversation too thank you
[Applause]